we have a truly huge piece of breaking news
that also is not going to make much of a difference
and may even be a misstep.
And I'll explain what I mean.
Um, the California governor is Gavin Newsome.
Gavin Newsome has signed a bill into law that
requires any presidential candidate who wants
to be on the California ballot for the presidential
primaries to release their tax returns.
Really sticking it to Trump now, right?
Except not really.
So I like this in the sense that I want Donald
Trump's tax returns.
I think he should release them.
I think it is obvious that he has made the
calculation that whatever is in the tax returns
going public is worse than the potential repercussions
of not releasing them, which have effectively
been zero because he was elected despite not
releasing the tax returns.
Yes, there are people still trying to get
them and it's an annoyance to Trump, but ultimately
he kind of made the right decision.
Assuming that there's something damaging in
those tax returns.
So I want to see the tax returns, but there
are some significant issues with what Gavin
Newsome is doing.
First of all, a Trump one without California,
Trump has no chance of willing winning California
in 2020.
And whether Trump is or isn't on the general
election ballot in California in 2020, it's
not really going to matter in the sense that
the Democrat is going to win California's
Ex, uh, electorial votes period.
So mathematically this doesn't matter in terms
of the election results, but maybe more importantly,
this is to get on the Republican primary.
Okay.
Donald Trump is not even going to face a serious
primary challenger.
Maybe he would have somebody in California,
uh, but ultimately it doesn't matter because
there's no leverage here.
This is merely that Donald Trump can't be
on the primary ballot in California if he
doesn't release his taxes and it's a state
he's going to lose anyway.
And then lastly, you also have to realize
that just because the governor has signed
something into the law doesn't necessarily
mean that it will stick.
It doesn't principal go into effect immediately,
but it's going to be challenged in court.
It's not totally clear if it is or isn't going
to stick.
There's an argument being made that it violates
the first amendment because it tries to tell
political parties who can your members vote
for or not vote for.
Right.
It is the state saying to the Republican Party
and the Democratic Party, your members are
not allowed to vote for someone who has not
published their tax returns.
And there are legal questions about whether
that would be allowed or not.
So I think that this is really interesting,
but the headlines are making a much bigger
deal out of this than it is.
This is not a big win for the left.
Trump was never going to win California.
The law is about being on the primary ballot.
Trump might not even be planning to campaign
in California other than holding presumably
some big money fundraisers and some of the
more conservative areas.
Uh, Orange County for example, in between
Los Angeles and San Diego, right?
Orange County, south of Los Angeles, I believe.
Uh, and I hate to tell you one other thing.
This is going to be used as justification
by Donald Trump to call the election rigged
against him.
Like I hate to bring this up.
It's completely unreasonable.
This is not a rigging of the election against
Donald Trump, but a state taking action that
might end up refusing a sitting president,
a place on the ballot is exactly the type
of thing that we'll let Donald Trump play
to his base by giving another example of how,
look that it's all rigged against me.
They're rigging the entire thing against me.
Now, there are similar proposals in other
states that would deal with the general election
if a candidate doesn't release their taxes.
Uh, and it could be potentially in states
that Donald Trump would actually have a shot
at winning until those get going.
This specific California decision is sadly
much to do about not very much.
And it may have had the unintended consequences
of giving Donald Trump and his cronies, not
only a stronger argument about it being rigged,
but it could get them to ramp up their voter
suppression efforts as well.
Under the guys that listen, they're doing
things they believe will help them.
We're doing things we believe will help us
and it will take an issue that really should
not be partisan.
I mean just people being able to vote and
having confidence that their vote will be
counted shouldn't be partisan.
It is in the United States, we've talked about
all of the ways in which it is partisan and
to is something that Republicans benefit from,
but if Republicans see what appears to be
a bill specifically targeting Donald Trump
via his taxes in California, even though California
is irrelevant to Trump winning, again, as
I mentioned, it is going to convince some
of those folks to look the other way on voter
suppression efforts by Republicans, which
they might otherwise call out.
So I don't know.
Let me open it to you.
What do you think about, this is my analysis
that it is not going to achieve anything for
Democrats and it may embolden Trump in some
ways, the right analysis.
Do you disagree with my analysis?
I want to hear from you, but bottom line,
I'm relatively unmoved about it and if I'm
missing something, I would love to know what
that is.